gol-do lolly lives and works in de Casas
re-bought neighborhood the name means a
thousand gardens but this is what her
front yard looks like do lollies family
and thousands of others are engulfed in
toxic chemicals spewed by more than two
hundred leather tanneries that dominate
the area under pressure to clean up
their act
the owners have pledged to leave Hazara
bog but few take them seriously
every year millions of cows are ritually
slaughtered across Bangladesh to mark
the Muslim Eid al-adha holiday when the
killing is done the hides are brought to
tanneries in the capital for processing
this is where the human misery begins
veteran tannery worker Munir hussein
suffers from rashes blurred vision and
headaches when he complains to his
bosses
he says they give him useless pills but
with six children to support taking a
day off is out of the question would you
allow them to work in a tannery when
they grow up
is it very common for children to be
working in the tannery industry a cheap
and bottomless labor supply has helped
turn Bangladeshi leather exports into a
billion dollar a year business but in
his re bog locals are paying with their
help one sealion handi-vac you are
inside a chamber of pollutants Philip
game directs the Society for environment
and human development a nonprofit that
has studied the social and environmental
impact of the tanneries we did a survey
ten years back we found that the people
having diseases say three hundred times
more than the national average
respite three diseases many people died
of cancer the tannery owners and the
government have been talking about
relocating the tanneries for years why
is it taking so long and who's at fault
the owners are very powerful the owners
are politically influential the owners
could violate the environmental laws and
no one could do anything inside the
tanneries giant wooden drums Chandra
hides and chromium sulfate and other
toxic chemicals to soften them Mohammed
earns just two dollars a day yet their
money long time
the Morison and they come on no did he
come talk so you have severe rashes and
infections on your legs your feet your
hands do all of your co-workers also
have similar problems now what well
that's that
dear employers know that you have these
health problems and what do they do when
you complain everywhere we went
tannery staff refused to let us film
working conditions inside for fear of
getting in trouble with their bosses
but one manager did finally agree to
take us on the tour when his tannery was
not in production you know height okay
mischievous for one because this is all
from me yeah eat from either go hike and
whereas most of this leather growing
this is for the export market
actually our
the share market begins to China China
hobo Jenny you don't be done then you're
up in Italy what's the price of a sheet
of leather like this wholesale $30 for
one piece no $30 for a square foot so
this is the tough quality leather yeah
this will be used to make handbags boots
okay what about your workers here is
there any risk to long-term exposure to
these chemicals do they have skin
problems do they have any breathing
problems no no no you know inside the
factory isn't no problem
workers are okay because it is as you
said yeah gloves rumbled and marks where
all these chemicals going when they're
done
so they get washed out and moist
through these pipelines in this goes
we're outside our said not outside India
in our factory is a big trend then is
going in and outside of factory more big
big day and where does that go and then
they'd go years in the river into the
river yeah how much waste would you
estimate that this factory discharges
every day into the river and began about
several thousand litres a day
so this factory alone is charging fifty
to sixty thousand litres everyday a
delivery Gunther this is a problem this
apart right now yeah
Cobra is a No
defending the government estimates the
nearly 8,000 tons of liquid waste is
dumped every day into the borea Ganga
river
daka's main waterway this could fill
three Olympic sized swimming pools
people can no more fish there people can
no more use the water
it's an unexampled and the level of
oxygen in the water is so little that
nothing can leave them this is basically
a Dead River and you can see if you get
close to it that it's actually bubbling
up because of all the gas and chemicals
that are in the water
it's absolutely filthy Bangladesh is
government wants the tanneries to move
to sävar an industrial suburb tannery
owners have dragged their feet for years
of her who should foot the bill ignoring
court order deadlines morally socially
we had all this possible but increasing
pressure from the government and foreign
buyers seems to be having an impact the
parking condition we cannot continue and
there's a real incentive to make this
change now because if not it could
impact your bottom line right only India
started losing business no brand buyer
is buying any letter from hajjali but
the Chinese government indirectly
imposed 17% duty but for of ramgopal
importing Bangladesh it's Korean
government aims to buy costella they
haven't stopped gone by from Bangladesh
at the Sauber site construction is
underway on a massive effluent treatment
plant that will process two and a half
million tons of industrial waste per day
some azhari bug tanneries including
Tijeras have started building other
people is it not followed there they
will follow it and when don't come here
they have to follow because it is a
compliance backing so if we come back
here yeah this time next year you will
see oh yes you see today honey house any
bank is closed I can assure you
but some worry that even if they move
the tannery owners won't change the
toxic methods there is a beautiful river
flowing by this new site I have the fear
that this Reba might also get affected
in this country polluters don't take if
anything goes wrong with the central
treatment plant then they might
immediately begin dumping people has no
idea in hazaribag what is compliance now
will have at least they're saying that
for compliance we have we are going to
Newton area effluent treatment plant was
do you worry a lot about your children
growing up here the kind of future
they're gonna have pasta Annunaki almost
are they giving us a solution on it
you